hello it's seven o'clock you're watching
the Sky News breakfast these are our top
stories this morning on Eurovision day
instead
[Music]
[Applause]
it's loud it's Brash but the contest
will be a showcase for Ukraine
incorporating its artists people and
scenes from across the war-torn country
[Music]
you're thinking of setting off to
Liverpool by train think again as train
strikes continue and services are badly
affected around the country
Sky News investigates how workers
claiming sick pay are being forced into
debt making do with a fraction of what
they need
so I ended up having um having just some
some gravy and some bread for dinner
just because you couldn't you just
couldn't afford it was either a roof
over your head or food and it's just no
one should have to choose
under attack from former Home Secretary
pretty Patel who's accusing him of
leading the managed decline of the
conservative party
love Island winner Finley tap tells us
how he's encouraging young footballers
to come up with a plan B in case they're
Let Go by their Club
the race for the top four is heating up
in the Premier League as much the United
boss Eric ten Haag fights to keep his
team ahead of Fifth Place Liverpool
and as of course too we'll take a look
at today's papers with national world
cities editor-in-chief Nancy Fielder and
a senior reporter for the eye Benjamin
Butterworth
[Music]
hello a very good morning and welcome to
Sky News breakfast as Liverpool prepares
for the biggest Eurovision party of all
time the route continues about whether
Ukraine's President zielinski should be
allowed to address the Grand Final he's
got the backing of Richardson and former
PM Boris Johnson but organizers say he
won't be allowed to speak because of
concerns that it would politicize the
contest well now the mayor of Liverpool
Steve Rotherham is trying to find a way
of giving him a platform
meanwhile excitement is building in a
city where music runs through its core
and it's promising to pay homage to
Ukraine throughout the event as our outs
and entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer reports
belting out Eurovision Classics in the
street
if you're a fan what more could you want
the UK has entered May Muller itching to
get started I thought I was excited
before but now I'm here I'm even more
excited and I feel like I'm just ready
to go now it's been so much build up and
then now I'm like it's basically here
for the first time we can show you this
a sneak peek at rehearsals and what the
160 million viewers expected to tune in
we'll see the production is immense
imagine being on the lighting desk with
000 lighting queues programmed in it's
no spoiler to say this is going to be
spectacular our concept and the
architecture of our set revolves around
a big hug I see if Liverpool is
welcoming the Ukraine Europe and the
world with big Open Arms incorporating
Ukraine is music and people is Central
to what you'll see in the show but Rishi
soon acts seemingly wanting in on the
action after hosting his own Eurovision
reception wading into the decision of
organizers not to let president
zielinski make an address over concerns
the event could become too politicized
insisting the values of what the
ukrainians are fighting for are not
political they're fundamental Eurovision
veterans jedward I think he might have a
point yeah I think it'd be like a great
way to thank the UK for hosting it for
Ukraine and I feel like the president
it's not so political I think he just
wants to share his love and thank the UK
for doing such a great job the show will
include 11 Ukrainian acts opening with
last year's winners kalusha Orchestra
we would like to say please vote for our
Ukrainian band don't forget about
Ukraine and keep supporting us but this
wouldn't be a party without the prospect
skirt ripping none of us will ever
forget you know we can remember every
minute of it so and it will be the same
for them but it's bigger better more
extraordinary more flamboyant more
colorful more fantastic now than it ever
was get ready to sing dance and bask in
Eurovision and all its Camp pop Glory
Liverpool is laying on quite the party
Katie Spencer Sky News in Liverpool
thank you well let's go live to our
correspondent Becky Cottrell who's at
the Eurovision Village in Liverpool for
us this morning so Becky to what extent
are we likely to see Ukraine in this
contest tonight and images from Ukraine
and are we likely to see president
zielinski at all
Ukraine will be heavily involved in the
production of this in terms of images in
terms of the opening performances but we
know we won't be seeing a video message
from president zelenski in not wanting
to make this event political the
organizers have very much made the
conversation about it a political one
now Liverpool's mayor Steve Rotherham is
that he does want to provide a platform
for Ukraine's president what could that
look like it's unclear but the council
are running a lot of this event on the
ground including that giant screen
behind me where thousands have been
queuing to get in and watch the acts
rehearsing but that wouldn't have the
same impact as seeing Ukraine's
president addressing that final 160
million people expected to tune in and
we'll have what we always have from
Eurovision 26 Acts battling it out and
in true Eurovision style there's
everything from heavy metal to ballad to
my own personal favorite Austria's entry
which is a bizarre number about being
haunted by the ghost of Edgar Allan Poe
that one is opening the show tonight
Sweden very much at the favorite uh
Finland also providing a very strong
Contender but we'll have to wait and see
how it goes on the night
of course yes thanks very much indeed
Becky
but if you're planning to set off to
Liverpool by train think again there's
another train strike today and for more
on that story our correspondent Aisha
zaheed is at London's Houston Station
and Aisha of course yesterday was a
strike by azleth workers today is the
rmt isn't it
morning Anna that's right and that's
what the problem is we've got two
different strikes almost running in
tandem with each other of course it was
as left the driver's Union uh that was
striking yesterday that affected 16
operators that's had not-on effects
going over spilling over into this
morning and then this morning rmt have
started their strike action it's
affecting 14 operators now all of this
of course comes on the weekend where
we've got the Eurovision final tonight
and then the women's FA Cup final
tomorrow government ministers pointed
fingers at the union saying that this
had been a targeted attack on Eurovision
preventing people from traveling for
that final but the union say that they
simply isn't the case of course all of
it comes down to this long-running pay
dispute and dispute over conditions that
they've got running with the government
no breakthrough moments there yet rmt
have rejected a nine percent uh pay rise
over two years and as left rejecting a
four-year a four percent pay rise a year
for the next two years so strike action
continues disruption continues though
mersey rails say that they're not going
to be affected but if you're traveling
to the Eurovision final from further
afield there may well be problems so the
message from operators is to check if
services are running before you set off
okay Aisha thanks very much indeed
now Rishi sunak is under attack this
morning from a familiar name his former
cabinet colleague the ex-home secretary
pretty Patel has lashed out at the Prime
Minister accusing him of being
responsible for what she says is the
conservative party's managed decline so
let's get more on that from our
political correspondent Rob Powell who's
in Westminster this morning it's quite a
fierce attack this isn't it from pretty
Patel Rob so what's behind it
I think what's behind it is a degree of
discontent about the local election
results last week and generally as well
about the direction the conservative
party's been going in pretty Patel is
going to make these comments at a
conference organized by a group called
the conservative Democratic organization
ostensibly a group that wants to give
more power to Tory members although a
lot of them are also very very loyal to
Boris Johnson and if we're being honest
we'd probably like to see him back in
Downing Street now pretty Patel will say
that Rishi sunak risks presiding over
the managed decline of the Tory party
um she'll say that he was a part of a
group that took down a vote-winning
political giant who was on course to
secure a record-breaking fifth
consecutive German election win for the
party of course referring um to Boris
Johnson and will say that some
colleagues in Westminster over the last
year have done a better job of damaging
the conservatives than the opposition so
clearly this indicates that in parts of
the conservative party anyway there is a
degree of anxiety about the direction in
which the party's going about those
results a week ago about about Rishi
sunak's um overall policy agenda in
terms of what actual direct impact it
will have on the Prime Minister though I
don't think at the moment there is
necessarily A tangible threat to his
Premiership I think most conservative
MPS quite frankly are quite sick of the
chaos and are prepared to give Rishi
sunak a little bit more time to try and
make advances on some of the economic
challenges is that he faces and
challenges with the NHS and obviously
with migration as well so yes an
indication of the anxiety that is still
there within the conservative party and
the fact that people are not afraid of
speaking out publicly about it but for
now I don't think it poses a tangible
threat to Rishi sunak okay Rob thanks
very much indeed
now many people living on sick pay are
sinking into debt struggling to afford
even the basics that's according to new
analysis shared exclusively with Sky
News the government wants to encourage
sick and disabled people back into the
workforce but it's failed to bring in
promised reforms to the system of
statutory sick pay Amanda acas reports
for all its Seaside Delights Margate in
Kent is one of the most deprived parts
of the UK many families struggle to make
ends meet and falling ill is often a
headlong plunge into poverty I'm in so
much debt because of it it's I I'm about
three grand
in debt from borrowing people getting
loans because I just couldn't
I couldn't fall to live couldn't get my
money couldn't get my rent Caira shop
assistants spent months unable to work
while waiting for surgery on her ankle
when the metal screws holding it
together after a childhood injury
snapped the statutory sick pay barely
covered half her rent it's just just not
enough I ended up having
um having just some some gravy and some
bread for dinner just because he
couldn't he just couldn't afford it was
either a roof over your head or food and
it's just no one should have to choose
Christopher has just been signed off
with depression from his job as a head
chef the statutory sick pay is only a
quarter of his normal income and the
stress is making his condition worse I
don't sleep I feel anxious most of the
time anyway and this just make me feel
even more anxious I'm just worried about
the whole situation like with the amount
of money that you actually don't get
while many employers choose to be more
generous with their sick pay a third of
workers only get the legal minimum
statutory sick pay is currently 109
pounds 40 a week which works out at
around a third of the full-time minimum
wage you only start getting it on the
fourth day in a row you've been off with
illness and if you earn less than 123
pounds a week on average your employer
doesn't have to pay it meaning two
million of the country's lowest paid
workers receive nothing at all the
campaign group's safe sick pay want to
see higher rates paid from day one
extended to all workers ministers
originally pledged to make improvements
in 2019 this former Justice secretary
says the time for Action is now we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people who through no fault of their own
might get ill and who end up staying off
work for longer because of the
disincentives that are caused at the
moment by the lack of reach of statutory
sick pay it seems to me that a reform to
statutory sick pay is overdue
the governments say they're implementing
a range of initiatives to help people
with health issues stay in work and
there's a strong safety net for those
with long-term conditions but none of
that helps Christopher now it's not just
me that's suffering us everybody else in
my family there's got to stop for me
being ill
dealing with a diagnosis is hard enough
for too many people it comes with
financial fear too
Amanda acass Sky News Margate
a former footballer is guiding young
players and encouraging them to think
about a plan B if they're dropped by
their Club Philly tab played for MK Dons
but was let go in 2019. he later found
success winning love Island he spoke to
our Sports presenter Jackie Bell trout
about living through a devastating
career setback
as soon as they sort of said they didn't
want me next year it was like you just
shut off and you don't want to hear the
reasons you just hear they don't want me
um and then I sort of walked into the
change room I didn't even really speak
to the other other guys in there and I
sort of went home did you cry yeah
yeah it was tough it's never too early
to start preparing yourself for the
worst outcome whether it's an injury
whether it's you get released whatever
it is your football career will come to
an end that might be 35 years old after
a full long successful career
um and it's just trying to prepare
yourself for what next what do I go into
um and I think it's important that the
boys you know they think what other
passions have I got what what other
things could I enjoy doing that allow me
money that will give me a career that I
can sort of strive and become the best
in that field do you think football
clubs then don't do enough right now to
help those young players and do they do
enough afterwards when they release
young players I wish there was more in
place for preparing boys
for the backup option I.E you can do
choose whatever you wanted to what
qualifications you wanted to do
alongside football and so I think that's
massively important to do more for that
and afterwards
um
sort of the love Island thing we had
sort of a welfare officer always
checking up on us it almost became
annoying it was that persistent it was
you know are you okay this that just you
know if you ever need anything contact
us so whether or not that's something
that clubs can do did you feel
embarrassed at the time when it happened
to you yeah I did yeah big time although
it's nothing to be ashamed of because of
the percentages are so small everyone
goes through it you do have that little
bit of you I guess that would be like oh
they're going to know that I don't play
football I've got a scene I'm going to
be seen as almost a failure in that
sense but
um I think that's a stigma we need to
Shake in that one setback isn't a failed
Mission it's just a little setback and
you can go in any direction that you
want
and you can hear a longer version of
Jackie's interview with Findlay tap at 9
30 this morning so do stay with us for
that
now the new post coronation photos have
been released and one shows King Charles
and his two heirs the Prince of Wales
and Prince George the king is wearing
his robe of estate and Imperial State
Crown and the other which you can see
here features the king and queen oh well
there's there's the one I was just
talking about and then the other one is
that with the pages of honor and ladies
in attendance the shots were taken by
Hugh Bernard who photographed Charles
and Cabela's wedding in 2005. Jackie's
here with the sport and I should be
talking about your Finley tap interview
which was brilliant but I am completely
distracted by sunshine in the weather
what
I don't know um yeah he was really good
yeah very nice chat very candid about
his experiences of being you know
dropped you know 10 years at a football
club from the age of nine and the
interview to tell you they don't want
you is 10 minutes he's like a bye and
that and that's it you're out the door
and that's the end of that well that's
the question and you know and then what
and a lot for a lot of players and their
families it's devastating because all
their dreams are pinned on being a
professional footballer and so few of
them make it uh the ones that do make it
do make it very very very very very well
that is all your support for now I will
see you in the last time
you're watching Skinny's breakfast
coming up we'll be speaking to the
government Minister Stuart Andrew a
Eurovision after the break
[Music]
well it's Eurovision day of course and
we're joined from Liverpool Now by
Stuart Andrew who's minister in the
department for culture media and Sport
so very good morning to you and I do
want to talk about Eurovision in just a
moment but um before we get on to that a
couple of stories around today that I
want to ask you about firstly comments
by the former conservative Home
Secretary pretty Patel today saying that
Rishi sunak needs to offer more hope and
optimism for conservatism or she says he
risks
presiding over a managed decline of the
party and defeat of the next election is
she right
so I you know I I have a marginal see I
am relying on the Grassroots of the
party to help me they are determined as
I am and I think most people within the
party to support the prime minister in
the Endeavors that he has to try and
grow the economy and tackle the issues
that are the people's priorities so I
think what they want us to do is to
unite to work together tackle those
issues and then go on to work towards
winning the next election
so comments like this from pretty Patel
are helpful then are they going to be
seen as sour grapes from a grieved Boris
Johnson supporters
look I'm not you know it's a privilege
for me to work with my colleagues I'm
not going to criticize them it's right
that we have discussion about the
direction of the party but I think what
is really crucial is that we focus on
those issues that the prime ministers
rightly identified because that's what
people tell us they want us to deal with
and that is what we will be focusing on
well yes and but some Tory members might
have some sympathy with her views
mightn't they they may say we didn't
actually vote for for Rishi sunak as
leader and we've now just seen him
presiding over terrible local election
losses with a thousand seats gone
well they were difficult elections of
course they are and you know I know from
my own constituency that hard-working
counselors had a really difficult night
but they equally want us to focus on the
issues that matter to the people of this
country that is what we are doing that
is what we need to concentrate on and
then work towards the next election it's
great to have debate but let's also
focus and unite behind those key issues
so that we can work towards victory in
the next election
do you think he does need to work on a
more conservative vision for the country
rather than just spending his time
trying to fix crises and problems
well look we've undoubtedly gone through
a very difficult time and it was right
that we were there to support people
through those cost of living issues and
but now he is focusing very rightly on
making sure that we are growing the
economy that's what people want they
want security they want to see better
standards of living and that is what we
are focusing on doing
is promising a vision he's talking about
a radical general election Vision he
says that the Tories are being
unconservative that they're failing to
understand people's need for stability
order and security and that might ring
true for some tourism isn't it
well I'm afraid I've heard Kia stama
relaunch himself so many times that I've
lost count and when I speak to people on
the doorstep I have to say that he's not
particularly resonating with them he can
do whatever he likes the fact is that we
are concentrating on growing the economy
making sure that we cut inflation a deal
with the small boats and make sure that
the NHS waiting lists are reduced so
these are key priorities the people I
speak to in my constituency and it's
right that we focus on those and we will
continue to do so
quick thought on how you think that's
going so far the bank of England this
week has revised its projections for
inflation up by the end of the year and
also the the latest growth figures
yesterday showed that in March the
economy shrank by 0.3 so those those two
priorities that you highlight there
aren't going so well at the moment are
they
well because we you know we have gone
through an incredibly difficult period
there's no doubts about that we haven't
made the promise that this will be
sorted out overnight but we are on a
plan the budget that the chancellor
announced uh specifically looked at many
of those issues to help us to grow the
economy and those are the issues that we
are focusing on rightly so
okay and one other issue that I did want
to ask you about because there are a
number of of head teachers as well as
um parents who are concerned about it
and this is the SATs test and one paper
in the SATs test this is for year six
pupils who are 10 and 11. they say that
that was extremely hard I think one head
teacher is talking about the test
including some GCSE level questions
what's your take on this was it too hard
so I mean my view is that I want all
children in this country to have the
very best education possible because it
is the foundation for their whole lives
and testing children and encouraging
their skills is an important element of
their education I think therefore you
know the the tests seem to me to be uh
fine and we need to you know continue to
do that there's a lot of work going on
in education to raise our standards so
that we have the best educated children
to compete in a very difficult global
economy
attention to Eurovision you are in
Liverpool of course and we've seen um
the Prime Minister and Boris Johnson as
well both expressed this appointment the
president zelenski isn't going to be
able to address the contest tonight
first of all do you agree with them
would you like to see an address from
him
I think yeah I think it is disappointing
that uh he's not able to make that
address that is a decision for the Ebu
it is their contest but actually if you
come to Liverpool what you see
everywhere you go are great uh you know
contributions from from Ukraine from
Ukrainian artists you cannot escape the
fact that this although this contest is
being held here in Liverpool you cannot
escape the fact that people know that it
should be held in Ukraine and I've spent
time yesterday with the Ukrainian
Ambassador and the culture ministers
from Ukraine and they were frankly
overwhelmed by what they had seen
Liverpool have put on an amazing show
and really made sure that that Ukrainian
influence is felt in every element of
this festival and competition here
oh we understand that the mayor of
Liverpool Steve Rotherham has said that
he's going to also speak to the
Ukrainian Ambassador and the mayor of
leviv who I think are both there to
discuss what could be done about
providing some sort of platform form
president zelensky what have you heard
about that and what form could that
potentially take
so I was speaking to both the Ambassador
and the minister last night about
options my understanding is the
president is very very busy but he he
has already sent a message saying how
grateful he is to the United Kingdom and
to Liverpool for hosting this show on
their behalf and I think everybody here
now is just focused on ensuring that
this contest continues to be as
successful as it has been all week and
you know I can get a sense from the
people here now that they're just
wanting to get on with the party
I'm sure they are but there'll be no
there'll be no site of president
zielinski at all tonight is is your take
on it yeah
that's my understanding that's a
decision the Ebu have made
um but you know despite that Liverpool
city council that combined Authority and
us and dcms have worked together to make
sure that there are lots of Ukrainian uh
things to see here lots of cultural
elements that have been installed for
people to look at and there will of
course be mentioned of the fact that we
are hosting this on behalf of Ukraine in
the contest this evening okay and very
briefly who's going to win
I will of course the United Kingdom but
I think also Scandinavian countries from
what I can see from the action of the
audience they're going to get a good
night too so who knows it's Eurovision
song contest anything can happen that's
so true Stuart Andrew thanks very much
indeed for your time we appreciate it
our members of the rmt Union are
striking today in England affecting
Services across 14 companies it follows
industrial action by aslev train drivers
yesterday which brought much of the
network to a halt well the r t General
Secretary Mick Lynch joins me now a very
good morning to you Mick Lynch first of
all just how much support do you expect
to have for the walkout today just how
disruptive will this strike be
what our members will be out all over
the country they'll be on picket lines
up and down the rail network we've had a
very strong mandate to renew our action
in the last week or so a nine to one
vote on a heavy turnout
so our members are up and down the
picket lines taking the action as
instructed by the union and as voted for
by them
and so the action is solid and it will
be as long as this campaign goes on
people watching will know that this
dispute has been going on for a long
time how close are you now to a
resolution
well we had an offer put to us the
second or third offer I think in this
this process which we have declined to
accept because
the the stipulations that were put on it
were not acceptable to our people we had
a good conversation about that
throughout the union so we're looking
for a fresh offer from the company we're
looking for
a new set of negotiations to start we
haven't got a settlement for the drivers
as you saw yesterday with the ads left
strike and we haven't got that for the
other grades in the RNG strikes as well
so
there's there's a lot of anger in the
rail industry at the minute both unions
are still campaigning they're members of
voting in heavy numbers to continue the
action so there's a lot of strength for
feeling and it's up to the government to
unblock this this dispute because they
they have the final say on what is
proposed at the table in their contracts
with these companies they stipulate what
the negotiating position is they
stipulate what the uh what the offers
are and those offers simply aren't good
enough at the minute they don't
recognize the cost of living crisis
where inflation has gone and what they
want from our members in terms of giving
up their terms and conditions are simply
not acceptable so there's a long way to
go but we're available for dialogue and
negotiation at any time
the government says they want you to put
this latest offer to a ballot of members
why aren't you doing that
because it's not acceptable it doesn't
meet the the demands in the dispute they
know that they knew knew that when it
was offered and certainly when they
clarified what they meant by what they
want us to do is call off the dispute
and then go into another set of
negotiations without any leverage at the
table we simply can't do that you don't
disarm yourself halfway through a
campaign and they're asking us to call
off all our action to declare that the
dispute is over when only half of the
issues have been negotiated so that's
not possible we're prepared to talk to
them and we're prepared to go into a
process but we're not prepared to call
off all of our action and declare the
dispute over when the issues have not
been settled so they've put a lot of
money into this dispute they've spent
over 1.25 billion on this dispute and
they've lost that money for the economy
and for the railway based on a Dogma
what we need is a practical solution to
the dispute so that we can get the
railways back to normal and the
government needs to show a bit of Good
Will and flexibility and stop wasting
the Public's money on this campaign
propping up private sector train
operators while they're making profit
our members are losing money and the
public are disrupted so we need a change
of stance from the government
immediately
so what are the key difference in this
dispute from the one with network rail
where you did ballot members and yet
you're not on this one so what are the
differences
well in network rail they made an
improved offer it's not the same offer
the drivers have only been off at eight
percent
over these two years and they haven't
had a pay rise for four years our
members have been offered nine percent
over those four years because we haven't
had a pay deal for such a long time
but in this one they are saying to us we
have to go into another round of
negotiations after we declared the
dispute over so what the demand was two
weeks ago was that we say that the
dispute has been concluded when the
issues have not been negotiated whereas
in network rail the issues were settled
they move forward with their modernizing
maintenance plan they enhance the offer
in cash terms so it's a superior offer
to the one that's available to train
operating companies they put a travel
facilities deal in it and there were new
contracts of employment for many of our
members that have got the potential to
improve their earnings over the rest of
their career so it's a completely
different offer for Network Rail and it
was a different picture the network rail
moves in a way that our members could
accept but the train operating companies
have not been allowed to do that by the
government okay so if the train
companies drop the request to get rid of
the your strike mandate would you put
that to the to the ballot is the rest of
the deal sound essentially
well the devil's no because it's the
network rail deal was a better deal it
had more cash in the offer than this one
it's in the technicalities of the way
the deal works so what we need to do is
get around the table and get a document
written down in a way that is clear it
was unclear in its first version and
that broke down because of the
interpretation so we'll be talking to
the companies next next week to see if
they want to get around the table and
fresh out a deal if we get a deal that
is clear in its meaning and we're
allowed to keep our or unable to keep
our mandate going so that we've got
leverage at the negotiating table
perhaps we can move forward but the
devil's always in the detail of these
documents and we'll have to see what it
says to see if we can move forward but
what's going on at the moment is the
government is wasting everybody's time
and money rather than allowing the
companies to negotiate and get a
reasonable Prospect in a deal
everybody's been put in a straight
jacket really so that we can't move this
dispute forward so hopefully we can do
that in the next week or two okay well
Mick Lynch we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at the weather
back to both of you and uh Ben we're
kicking off with you this hour and we've
dealt with a lot of the front pages last
time around and on the front of your
newspaper was a call by pretty Patel or
criticism really of her of the of the
Prime Minister and the guardian picks up
on this group that she's part of and
there's a big conference today isn't
there so what's the guardian saying yeah
so this is the conservative Democratic
organization which is a group frankly I
hadn't heard of until very recently and
the guardian makes a very good point
that the people who are speaking at this
conference today it's not just pretty
Patel it's at Jacob Reese MOG it's uh
Nadine dory's now what do they have in
common they're all pretty fond of that
guy who used to be prime minister Boris
Johnson and so the suggestion they're
making which the organizers of this
group have rather unconvincingly denied
is that actually this big Conference of
the Tory right today is about getting
Boris Johnson back in power back as
prime minister because this is basically
all of their backers several of the
people that were funders of Boris
Johnson's political career including
Aaron Banks who was a big fund of the
brexit side of things and used to fund
ukip in the past they're all involved in
this group and I think that you know
when we saw those local election results
and Rishi sunak lost well over a
thousand Council seats and there was a
question for the last week of well is
there not a move to to get rid of him
that's what usually happens if a leader
doesn't do well I think this is it and
and this group that's got proper money
big names I think is going to be the
vehicle to try and get Boris Johnson
back into Downing Street I'm not sure
how well that will go quite frankly but
I think that's the attempt what I was
going to say I mean could they have a
chance if we should see like performance
doesn't improve might they have more
traction I mean the Parliamentary Tory
party doesn't look like on mass it's
it's looking to get rid of Richie sunac
I think that would be a gross
exaggeration and also Boris Johnson's
just bought a four million pounds house
he's getting you know he's made a
million pounds in one quarter uh from
speeches and all the rest of it I think
he's probably raking the money in but
waiting for that moment when he can
strike and I suspect this group is
trying to put it in the place where
where that will be plausible when it
gets there when the ball comes out from
the back of the scrum yeah he's going to
be ready to said oh I was doing tennis
but uh I think oh yeah
you're watching the wrong kind of tennis
that's why I'm not a sports
correspondent I think definitely not
okay Nancy take us to the guardian a lot
of attention on Eurovision of course
today not least because it's been hosted
by the UK and the reason why it's being
hosted by the UK there's an article here
in the guardian
yes of course it's been a very long time
coming getting your vision back to the
UK it's in Liverpool I mean Liverpool is
an incredible City and it's really
really thrown all its weight behind it
and been really building up to this for
weeks and months but obviously it should
never have been in Liverpool originally
it should have been in the Ukraine so
this is a really interesting article
about sort of the politics of it now you
did a piece earlier about how the
Ukrainian president hasn't been invited
to give a speech or send a video message
however Eurovision is always quite
overtly political but not politicians
standing there talking to you but it
comes through in the music it comes
through in the costumes it comes through
in the dance it comes through in
everything so I think we are going to
have a massive show of support for you
create tonight obviously they are the
co-hosts even though really sadly they
can't host in their own country and the
guardian saying there's a very good
chance that the Ukraine will win
Eurovision is also well known for
perhaps not the best musicians winning
but um political allies supporting each
other so it's just going to be a really
really big celebration I'm bringing the
Ukraine back to the front pages and back
into sort of everybody's thoughts
because it does fade away doesn't it
after a year of War sadly it doesn't for
them but it has for us I think this is a
brilliant opportunity to celebrate but
also to to look at an ongoing situation
which shows no end of War sadly no
that's right and and you pick up on this
theme Benjamin you've written an article
in the eye haven't you uh that's that
yeah talks about exactly what it means
to Ukraine so I interviewed the lead
singer of colush Orchestra which is the
Ukrainian rap band that won Eurovision
and I spoke to them yesterday and I put
that question about should zielinski be
allowed to speak now very diplomatically
uh they just wouldn't answer the
question because Eurovision rules are
really strict about politics in fact if
you roll the clock back one year they
wanted to keep Russia in the contest
because they said removing them would
have been a political act but then
everyone else in the contest said well
we're not going to turn up if Russia's
there but what they want and I'm not
sure how likely this is to happen but
they say if the UK wins tonight uh which
would be amazing and may Muller is our
our brilliant singer but if she wins
tonight they want to do another Swap and
so that we would give Eurovision to
Ukraine a free UK Crane in 2024 now I
think that we're probably not going to
win I don't know it seems unlikely I I I
blame me if we lose
um and also I think Ukraine might still
sadly not be an estate to to host such a
large contest but I think you know the
other thing that the the lead singer
said is that it's been such a morale
boost and you can only imagine you know
it must feel as as Nancy rightly points
out that the world is forgetting about
the plight that it's becoming old news
you know because you constantly new ways
to get it back there and and the close
Orchestra said to me that it has boosted
the morale so much to see the solidarity
in Liverpool and in Britain since they
arrived so you know I think we should be
proud of what we're doing and how we're
helping and doing this with Ukraine
today yeah I mean it's always a very
uplifting contest anyway isn't it but
it'll have that extra layer of it are
you all set like most gaming in this
country I love Eurovision you've got a
party all planned I uh I will be doing
yeah I might have uh well you see you
always want to yeah when I have nibbles
and drinks from all around the different
countries don't you I genuinely think
that's that's the best part I haven't
even thought that I said obviously but I
was just thinking nibbles and drinks I
just got stuck
rude although that's not a bad idea
anyway let's move on
to the story this is in the mail I think
Nancy be fair to Fat workers New York
tells the bosses so talk us through it
yeah this is a really interesting
ongoing situation in America where more
than 40 of the population are obese and
this is a new bill that's making its way
through the legislations in New York
City which means you can't legally
discriminate against fat people so this
covers all sorts of things off
um it's just a fact that overweight
people are paid less particularly if
you're an overweight woman you you more
likely to get sacked everything's going
against you really so this will make
that illegal it's an interesting one
though because it goes beyond the
workplace so criticizes our saying it
also means if you get a taxi and there
isn't a seat belt extender well that's
discrimination you can sue them if you
go to a restaurant and there isn't a
seat that's comfortable big enough for
you you can sue them so it's very very
interesting one obviously everybody
should be protected from discrimination
nobody should be paid less because for
any physical reason but actually this is
a massive massive issue perhaps the
wrong word this is a important issue
that is being discussed but it is also
going to cause all sorts of
controversies so I think it's one to
watch and one that possibly might be
heading our way at some point in the
future
okay yeah a really interesting one and
um we don't have time for the star whose
front page has a typical kind of
humorous slant on what's actually a
serious story so Benjamin I'm going to
encourage you to bring that one back
I'll bring it back in the next hour and
we'll talk about it then because we're
out of time this hour but uh good to see
you both at Nancy and Benjamin and we'll
see you again in an hour uh in the
meantime still come on Sky News
breakfast we'll have a live update from
Liverpool as its mayor speaks of trying
to get Ukraine's president on the
platform
foreign